[Music]
hello and welcome to the security zone
here at Google next we're here with Maya
an expert in infrastructure security
thanks for being here Maya thank you for
having me Cassie so I'm so glad that
you're here because I would love to know
more about how you provide security for
users and employees at Google of course
by some accounts schools Network
delivers more than 25 percent of
infinite traffic so our infrastructure
is super critical and security is one of
our highest priorities for that global
infrastructure so if I'm running a
business how do I use Google cloud
infrastructure to protect my data let's
walk through an example to start off say
you upload a file into Google Drive from
ur pixel book slide this photo of a
really cute dog here and I want to save
that for later so I'll just drag that
into Google Drive and it uploads and
that happened super fast let's break
down what happened to that file and how
it will secure it along the way let's do
it
so when you connect to a mobile service
over the internet Google requires that
the connection is encrypted that means
that data that you sent to Google will
be encoded in transit so it can't be
read by most just a third party
connections to Google services come into
our network through Google front end
servers which terminate your connection
and provide encryption using the HTTP
protocol so my data is encrypted in
transit to Google without me having to
do anything yeah that's right the Google
front end also wrote your request to the
right service so once it's inside
Google's infrastructure your data
travels over a network backbone and
might go to another location let's say
that in your case to reach its
destination your file travels across a
Google owned undersea cable you mean one
of these things exactly those are
undersea cables that we have under the
sea and so you'll see there there's a
fiber-optic cable right in the middle
surrounded by multiple layers of steel
and they even have you know shark-proof
armor and rubber coverings because of
that that's an issue that we have to
encounter Google operates on one of the
largest backbone networks in the world
it connects our data centers was with
hundreds of thousands of miles of
fiber-optic cable
the wool lines here represent the
current Google Network and the green
lines indicate new network cable
cyclicals developing so the files been
encrypted in transit to Google's Network
and then sent to the right place over
Google's global private network so what
happens to the file next next we'll
store the file that you uploaded on one
of Google servers customer contents
stored by Google cloud services like
Google Drive is encrypted at rest by
default here's how that works
the file that we uploaded is first
chunked broken up into pieces and each
chunk is encrypted with its own data
encryption key each data encryption key
is then wrapped using a key encryption
key which is stored centrally the
encrypted chunks and their keys are
distributed across Google's storage
infrastructure for security and
reliability if your file is updated its
reinserted with a new key rather than
reducing the existing key as a result of
this process if a bad actor wanted to
access data they would not only need all
the pieces of the file which are spread
out across multiple servers but they
would also need access to all of the
case so the file is automatically
encrypted at rest on Google servers
that's right without you having to take
any action let's take a look into the
servers protecting the file and how
they're protected we design our own
Hardware at Google as well as our own
software to make sure that we have
complete control over our infrastructure
Google servers contain a custom Google
tightened security chip titin helps to
make sure that no unauthorized machines
or software operate on our network if
titin is not present or Titan can't
verify the integrity of the server
software the server will not boot that
means a malicious actor can't start up a
fake service for example and get access
to your data if everything is as
expected the machine comes online and is
ready for action
this is a real Titan ship there are
chips like these and servers across
Google's infrastructure that protect
Google servers like the one I uploaded a
file to these servers sit in Google own
data centers the physical security of
these data centers is yet another level
of protection Google data centers
include metal detectors secure access
cards and biometric scanners data
centers are monitored 24/7 by high
resolution interior and exterior cameras
have large fences some threatening local
wildlife like alligators in some
locations and vehicle access barriers to
protect unauthorized entrance into the
data center so let's summarize the whole
thing then the file we uploaded is
encrypted in transit when it's
travelling outside our physical
boundaries encrypted at rest by default
and protected in google designed and own
servers security chips and data centers
exactly and millions of files are being
uploaded every day to global cloud that
are being protected by this global
infrastructure well thanks Maya for
taking us through the journey of file
takes as it makes its way securely from
the device to the data center my
pleasure
[Music]